hello and welcome to Playstation grenade
today we are playing extinction I've
been looking forward to this for so long
basically extinction is all about saving
human beings rescuing the world from
huge Rivini which are massive
orga light creatures which we have to
cut down to size and I'm being quite
literal there
so our first revenge were coming up to
it now it has armor it has armor its
legs its arms and shoulders and its head
so we have to figure out how to bring it
down to size but if you look in the
bottom right hand corner the red bar
indicates my health and the one next to
it the yellow bar looks like fire is all
about when we can kill a ravenna has to
be filled all the way to the top my
favorite way to fill the bar is to take
down the armor eater eveni has this set
has these locks which we need to hit
twice if we do so then the leg will be
exposed meaning if we don't get hit we
can run straight back in there use our
room strike and chop off this goddamn
leg but be careful they do tend to flail
around like idiots oh you but be very
quick and what you do next once again
though the gauntlets are just the same
and we just need to hit the lock twice
and I can get near the bloody thing stop
trying to hit me a big bastard if I can
get near enough and he has no more armor
on this side and once again if we can
get close enough we can perform a room
strike just below his elbow and we can
take off his arm this is really useful
if I have a weapon as well they can
bruise his legs come back again so we
come straight back in as soon as it pops
back in chop the top again we need to
keep him on the ground we're doing quite
well right whilst this has been
happening we now have enough energy in
our sword to be able to chop his head
off so I'm just gonna run up his arm get
on his shoulder trying not to fall off
then line up at the base of this skull
and then just chop the bloody thing off
but I think it really feels good to know
and it's a case of doing that on this
level four times let's see what armor
this one has
oh it's wood it's just simple wood armor
on this guy this should be easy enough
we can hit these little shin pads
anywhere we like to knock them off
sometimes a good idea to back off to see
how aggressive they are but I just like
to run in a trench off their limbs as
soon as possible when they hit the
ground
just be careful oh yeah they really do
flail about depending on their mentality
some of them sit quite still for you and
let you do let you get on with your work
but some of them will attack you
instantly and it is a one-hit kill in
some scenarios so what I'm going to do
now is get my flaming bar higher so we
can perform the kill animation so I'm
going to go around all four of his limbs
take off each bit of the armor take off
the actual limit self and then hopefully
we have enough no we don't so we need to
fight some of the minions now so we have
enough energy to perform at the end
strike did you notice as well in the
background his leg grew back we have to
be very aware because once you all the
link will grow back except for his head
so be very careful when he running
around because they will suddenly smash
you and you won't realize right we take
the helmet off we should have enough
energy now to be able to kill it which
we don't okay right we see one more
minion to kill
there we go kill strike ready so
straight back up we know how to line
this up now get on the back of his neck
press L to line it up and your head is
no more sir no just a figure out why I
like this so much I must be some sort of
serial killer in disguise okay let's
find another one
200 meters away let's get over there
let's see what kind of armor this chap
has he is oh he's a good-looking fellow
right what you're wearing darling
yes Goths one metal what I want wooden
one so we're getting mixed sets now so
your tactics will have to change very
Triveni that you base it on each level
the revenge will change their
personality will change slightly their
armor will change and the world itself
will be randomly generated so you
shouldn't play the same level twice
unless you're at certain points in the
camp I should have been paying attention
okay right there you go the one hit kill
it does show you it can be quite
infuriating at times but that's part of
the challenge alright we have another
guy he's wooden this shouldn't take too
long
[ __ ] off is leg
goodnight one go I started to get good
at this as he comes down trying to take
his arm out fast now mess that up
we got lucky we should be killed there
we got so lucky speaking of not dying
there there are some levels where it
stays you cannot die but those can be
changed as well so if you're not very
good at getting through these levels
without dying then you can change the
modifier there may be more of any to
kill them maybe more humans to say there
may be more of these little Jack of
green cute creatures running around
which you have to eradicate instead of
the bosses so there were many different
modifications and variations to each
level let's get back on this guy's back
and this should be another one down is
this three or four that's three now
isn't it right so we just need to kill
one more of any to finish this which is
the sixth level of the campaign mission
so let's get over there 240 meters away
come here he's got a helmet on so we
have to remember that when we go for
this the final strike and he seems quite
dormant he doesn't have a weapon that's
good it's already lobster lake this
should be easy this should be easy he's
not wearing armor there we're gonna need
some more power though if you look at
our bottom right corner we need more for
our fatal rune strike so we need to get
involved in more action kill more of
these little Jackyl creatures and be
ready to take down this guy as soon as
we can so it's not just about getting up
there and killing them you have to think
about your surroundings you have to
think about in some levels you have to
rescue so many civilians that you'll be
running to a revenge chopping his legs
off then running away again trying to
find more humans to save which are being
attacked by those little green jackal
things okay so he's got steel armor on
one side so we need to find the lock we
need to hit it twice and then
we can get his other leg so he's not
getting up for a while now so we can
work on his arm 100 let's get out the
way of that don't want to die twice in
one game try and get his arm off
oh he's not happy there goes his arm
we've got a kill strike ready
his legs are growing back oh let's take
his leg out again exam as well yeah
let's just best be safe rather than
sorry
dodge of that ooh
oh please amp it okay I didn't mean to
do that oh let's just get up his back
let's just get up there and get this
done
knock off his helmet I notice that when
he throws you back and you quickly do
another room so I can get back on his
shoulders again and then one barroom
strike and kaboom it's all over all four
killed we have so much XP from that and
look at that lovely blood really
enjoyable so that's it that's extinction
that's just one of the levels so once
complete you will see this success
screen and this is what feeds into the
RPG elements inside extinction so in the
bottom right corner I have 4340 skill
points to spend so I can press r1 and
these are all the things we can buy we
can have more health we can rescue
civilians quicker which is really
important for how I play we can jump
higher there are so many ways to feed
into this so when you come back to an
earlier level with a higher level
character you can absolutely eradicate
the records here's a little look at the
next level I need to execute the gold
armor Triveni but there are also bonus
medals on offer like kill you one of the
remaining with two missing limbs
destroying multiple pieces of armor
there are so many little modifications
to each level which make you want to go
back and play again and there's even
daily challenges in extinction anyway
I'm talking far too much I wanted to
show you extinction what do you think
I'd love to know your thoughts in the
comments I'm Adam from Playstation
grenade I'll see you next time
you
[Music]